العالم كله يشوف اغمضوا عيونهم واغلقوا
كاميراتهم حتى لا يروا واقعا ينقض مزاعم
المستشرقين الاوروبيين عن الشرق الموصوف
في ادبيات بالتوحد وكي لا يكتشف من يشاهد
شاشاتهم ان الوحوش الضاريه التي تقتل
الاطفال والنساء والشيوخ في ذلك الجزء من
العالم قد وفدت اليه من الغرب الذي لا يكف
عن وصف نفسه
قيدوا بل منعوا نشر صور الموت الذي يصنعه
رسل حضارتهم بين شعوب يعتبرونها بدائيه
متخلفه وتحت ذريعه مراعاه الحس الانساني
للمشاهدين عاقبوا بالحظر والتغييب عن
وسائل الاعلام الاجتماعي كل من جر على
التذكير باسم وصفات وتاريخ وحاضر البلاد
التي تعرضت ولا تزال لاعت اشكال الغزو
الاستعماري الاستيطاني وواجه شعبها اشد
حملات القمع والاقتلاع والتشريد من ارض
وطنه طوال
عقود لكن تعتيمه الاعلاميه المفروضه على
ما حدث ويحدث ظل اقل من كاف لحجب المذبحه
عن ابصار من رفضوا اغماض عيونهم او تحييد
كاميراتهم واذ خرجت جموع بشريه هائله في
انحاء مختلفه من العالم لتصرخ قائله كفى
فان القوه الباغيه لم تجد سبيلا لاخفاء
تفعل غير فرض الظلام والصمت بالقوه لا
كهرباء ولا وقود ولا اتصالات لهذه
الحيوانات التي لها شكل البشر وفق تعبير
سافر العنصريه استخدمه احد قاده
الحرب كان اغراق ما يزيد على مليوني انسان
في الظلام وعزلهم كليا عن العالم ليومين
متتاليين في زمن تسوده ثوره الاتصالات
واخر ابداع تفتقت عنه عقليه الغزات
ليمنعوا اي احد من ان يرى او يسمع او
يستنكر ما يقترفونه من مذابح تحت شعار
الصراع بين الحضاره
والهمجيه من هم هؤلاء الغزات ومن اي عرق
وما هو دينهم ثم من يكونون ضحاياهم ومن اي
عرق وما هو دينهم ايضا تلك هي الاسئله
التي تحل محل قدسيه الدم الانساني ليبنى
على اجوبتها موقف القوى المهيمنه على
المجتمع الدولي ولا باس من بعد في نفض
الغبار عن القرارات والمواثيق الدوليه حين
تقتضي الحاجه او ابقائها هناك تاكلها
العثه في حال لم تلزم اذا قيل هنا ان
الكلام السابق يدور عن بقعه جغرافيه في
اوروبا تعرضت للغزو ويواجه اهلها القتل
فسيه الغرب بامريكيه واوربيه لنصرتها
مشهرا على سنه الصواريخ كل القوانين التي
تمنع الاستيلاء على اراض الغير بالقوه
وتمنح هذا الغير حق مقاومه الاحتلال
اوكرانيا مثال فاضح على وقوفهم بكل ما
يستطيعون لفرض الشرعيه الدوليه حين يكون
الضحايا من بني جلدتهم اما فلسطين وهي من
يدور الكلام عنها الان فمثال اخر يكمل
الفضيحه كما يعتقد بنوها لانها كشفت كيف
يلقون بالقيم الانسانيه في حاويات
النفايات عندما يكون الجلاد حليفا لهم
وكيف تحل الاساطير الغابره محل القوانين
المعاصره لانشاء الدول وكيف تصبح محرقه
ارتكبتها النازيه ضد اليهود قبل 80 سنه
سياقا تبريري لسياسه دوليه لا تكتفي
بالتسامح مع اشعال احفاد الضحايا محرقه ضد
شعب اخر بل تعتبر اي دفاع عن النفس في
مواجهه جرائمهم شكلا من اشكال العداء
لساميه يلا
ستتعثر الفلسطينيين كما تعالت على مر
التاريخ مذكرين بانهم ساميون ايضا وبانهم
لم يكونوا طرفا في اضطهاد اليهود وبان من
غير العدل ان يدفعوا ثمن جريمه اباده
ارتكبها الاوروبيون انفسهم سيقدمون الادله
على ان الارض التي يعيشون عليها هي وطنهم
الذي لا وطن لهم سواه منذ الوف السنين بيد
ان القوى الدوليه تواطئه ضدهم ستحاول غض
النظر عن اغلاق الفضايا امام اصواتهم
وستبارك فرض الظلام على نزف جروحهم وعلى
تدمير بيوتهم فوق رؤوس اطفالهم لتواصل
التغني بالنور الذي يشع من تمثال الحريه
في نيويورك ويضيء العالم
باسره